alors comme ça il paraît qu'à droite on
ne s'intéresse pas à l'écologie ah bon
en 1945 au sortir de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale la France du général de Gaulle
anticipe les dangers de la prolifération
nucléaire avec la création du
Commissariat à l'énergie atomique ou CEA
un an plus tard il écrira même dans son
carnet de note en paraphrasant château
brillant les forêts précèdent les
civilisation les déserts les suivent en
1960 la notion de parc naturel fait son
apparition afin de protéger la
biodiversité et en 1964 à cette même fin
certains gibiers sont interdits à la
vente et on instaure le principe de PO
payer il faudra ensuite attendre 1971
pour créer l'ancêtre du ministère de la
transition écologique le ministère de la
protection de la nature et de
l'environnement et c'est Robert poujad
qui hriite de ce portefeuille sous
l'impulsion de Jacques Chaband Delmas
Premier ministre de George pompid c'est
Valérie giscardestin qui en 1976
introduit les statuts d'espèces et
d'espace protégé avec la loi sur la
protection de la nature il offre même
aux associations une reconnaissance
officielle leur donnant du même coup la
capacité d'intenter des actions devant
la justice il expliquera dans un
entretien au Monde en 1978 sa volonté de
réconcilier l'économie et
l'écologie plus tard en 1990 Michel
Barnier publie un rapport sur
l'environnement où il demande à François
mitteran de faire les mêmes efforts
budgétaaires sur l'environnement que sur
la culture 5 ans après la Barnier visera
à protéger les zones à risque en les
identifiant et en prenant des mesures
nécessaires à leur protection pour
réduire les conséquences de potentiell
catastroph le programme national de
lutte contre le changement climatique
voit le jour en 2000 sous la présidence
Chirac qui sensibilisera le monde entier
à la cause écologique 2 ans plus tard
lors du 7e Sommet de la Terre notre
maison brûle et nous regardons ailleurs
en 2004 la Charte de l'environnement est
créée et entraîne avec elle un plan
climat avant d'être intégré au bloc
constittu
2005 en 2007 à l'initiative de Nicolas
SAR Jean-Louis borlau portera la
création du Grenel de l'environnement
qui permettra l'adoption de loi à
l'unanimité par l'Assemblée nationale et
le Sénat en 2009 et la loi d Grenel 2
portant sur l'engagement national pour
l'environnement sera adopté en
[Musique]
2010 malgré ses avancées majeures initié
à chaque fois par la droite nous le
savons la tâche est immense
face au discours caricaturaux de la
technocratie ou de la décroissance nous
voulons une politique environnementale
concrète donc fondée sur la science et
respectueuse des libertés individuelles
bref une écologie du développement et de
l'adaptation et si on sortait l'écologie
des prophéties tristes pour l'ancrer
dans l'action et si on investissait
massivement dans les nouveaux
développements de la filière nucléaire
car ce qui est certain c'est qu'elle
accuse 10 ans de retard faute de
décision politique et si on étendait
notre dispositif européen de taxation
car pour que la réindustrialisation
aille de PA avec l'écologie et si on
décarbonait notre économie grâce à
l'incitation et non la punition et si on
doublait la part du frit ferroviaire en
soutenant des grandes infrastructures et
si nous construisions ensemble une
écologie du possible et si enfin on se
mettait un peu plus au travail en
faisant un peu moins culpabiliser les
Français pendant près de 3 He nous
allons réfléchir
ensemble à dessiner les contours d'une
écologie de droite c'est-à-dire une
écologie très ambitieuse climatiquement
mais acceptable supportable
économiquement et
socialement